you are like royalty they will treat you
know feed yer they'll try everything you
know they can't give you enough Joe mean
on the whole in process and everything
are and throughout you know they're
really hospitable and they're really
glad that you're there and help the
cause the first thought dare we meet
south in James rocked up we were dead
interested to know where the ice
positions were obviously just two
massive thing to know where the art okay
they're so like you know we went out
with one of the one of the Kurdish Lud's
and two of the Americans and we're just
showing us the expositions I would
reaffirm that was this is no man's land
this is a berm line you know nobody goes
beyond this they don't come be on this
and straight away from that feel it was
like no man's land a bone line like
world war one type feel about it in or
meaning it was the lobby is just dead
ground between us between our PB and
their PB is just dead ground in just a
bone line and that in its sense was like
an eerie feeling